comes bacon who's hit a lot of time in
the G League this year Tembo with that
lethal step back step back comes into
the league as an undersized guard who
was specially this getting into that
painted area the mid-range bunch of the
G League as well as we mentioned and he
is been a great addition to the rotation
Walker knocks down his first three ball
tonight Mucha [ __ ] so Emil Jefferson is
jerel Martin both on the floor right now
Oscar with a wicked crossover that's
just the stop start ability this guy's
so special to stop the start the meal
Jefferson's a good defender not good
enough walk around the baseline a little
magic underneath
he's so slippery isn't he you feeling
generous on the last day of the regular
season and assist guys are trying to get
their numbers doors got those bonuses
kicking in all about the space and you
convinced Rashard Lewis to play the four
spot something he had said he didn't
want to do and they were head of the
crew they were ahead of the curve no
question Walker put it on a platter got
the layout and he can go inside-out
right they they run the post up out of
the timeout and that time he creates his
own boy temple Walker
nice haven't already noticed Detroit
leading by 24 without Blake Griffin
tonight
Walker doing all he can to will his team
into the playoffs he's got 22 through
the truck tonight and in ovulates
powerhouse an excellent defensive
players with penny wolf same verbiage
everything guys now could actually
request the opportunity to get down to
the chilly just a state game ready as he
des moines's in this quarter
Kemba Walker Antonio Spurs was interim
head coach for the Orlando Magic for Y
you could tell Marc and interacting with
a lot of the guys from Orlando John and
Jeff Wellman how about great coaching
jobs this year
what about Doc Rivers doing it without
an all-star after trading Tobias Harris
arguably a best player this year is
close he's so close to breaking out and
the stairs down his defender and drills
it just been a big part of what Orlando
has died walker inside with another
bucket
that's going to give him 41 on the night
[Applause]
off the bridges screen wow I thought he
got Denver again but that was a man want
continuation